une sonde pour mesurer de manière
indépendante la radioactivité le projet
qui pourrait voir le jour sur la commune
d'andrésy c'est l'objectif de
l'association yvelinoise nucléaire je
balise un collectif d'une vingtaine de
militants actifs co créé par gilles
cousin la sonde
elle est pour toute l'île de france à
partir du moment où elle sonne c'est
qu'il ya une pollution radioactive assez
importante parce qu'effectivement il n'y
a pas énormément d'installation en
ile-de-france informations et
transparence sur la radioactivité c'est
tout l'enjeu autour de cette sonde les
résultats seraient répertoriées et
analysés par l'association criirad
la commission de recherche et
d'information indépendantes sur la
radioactivité
il existe des sondes officiel mais ce
sont des sondes dont qui dépendent en
grande partie de l'état évidemment
certains acteurs du nucléaire
donc il nous semble important démocratie
qui est une autre source est évidemment
une source indépendante d'informations
pour être accompagné dans sa démarche
l'association a sollicité la
municipalité la commune trouve un
intérêt dans ce projet une
sensibilisation aux citoyens du risque
environnemental qui est malheureusement
qui peut arriver tout le temps par et d
impact aura dires des industriels ou
environnementaux le coût de l'achat et
de l'installation de cet équipement
atteint les 45000 euros
l'association a répondu à l'appel à
projets dans le cadre du budget
participatif de la région objectif
obtenir une subvention de 10000 euros le
reste fera l'objet d'une campagne de
financement citoyenne